okay i have 111 pending challenges
this time i'll play a random just a
random person
um so there's a one in
100 plus
yeah there's a lot less than one percent
chance this doesn't count
uh of getting the next game in my book
oh
haha okay anyway
new game 10 minute game
playing random champ gamer oh who has a
high rating
higher than my previous opponents
i think i'm i'm down to play ponziani
yeah ponziani time
i was saying earlier like ponziani it's
an effective opening
against kind of beginner players
um against higher rated players it can
still be kind of a surprise weapon
there was a point in time i played this
in like serious over the board games
i didn't have the best score with it and
d5 is considered one
to be one of the best moves here so
after d5 queen a4 is
uh is usually the the go-to
also kind of a tricky response as i pin
the knight
threatening to win this pawn
hey it's gary thanks gary
subbing for seven months
now i have a youtube video where i play
vanguard
in this exact position vanguard played
d5
i played queen a4 and
it's not easy for black to figure out
the best line especially if the player
hasn't seen the position before
whoa it's talking you take my bits
i'll gladly take tigey's bits thank you
tagi
i know taki had like a hard time
replenishing the bits
i think recently but
i guess you figured figured out how to
how to get more i appreciate that
and thank you c-s-w-a
subbing for three months so f6 is the
best move
there's really not too many other great
moves that um effectively defend the
pong
um now bishop b5 is the main line
and this line like at a very high level
it's considered dubious for white
but i'd say any level below
like gm there's there's a lot of life to
it
there's a lot of like complex variations
too
but for the time being white gets some
early initiative
if black tries to break the pin it
leaves the pawn undefended
yeah 97 again is a is theory
this is all still theory
and thank you sporadic one two three
oh and there's a sip tea redemption i
think i did sip tea
i'll sip more tea i'm drinking
first of all i'm drinking out of the
tagi mug
and i'm drinking
brain boost green tea
it's like super green something japanese
matcha
okay so asics
there are cases where asics isn't a
threat because it's a pin
but it's kind of a threat because
the queen wants to take
trying to remember there's another line
like e4
then c4 i'm wondering
if c4 makes sense here
maybe not i think in this position i
should just take the knight and then
play d4
there's also bishop c4
there are options here sway bishop c4
bit bit bit oh
oh that's a new is that a new name moose
army
pulling a a tagi or some some form of
tagi
just repeating the same word and
cheering bits i appreciate that
so i'm keeping my bishop because uh uh
especially given the pawns on
on dark squares here oh make it please
is on a 12 month
uh subscription courtesy of 95 horatio
special thanks to jon
has done oh has done three months
okay i think it's time to play d4
d4 love from armenia bit bit bit bit bit
thanks for sharing the love in the form
of bits
i played this move too there's actually
a few
like interesting moves to consider here
i mean d4 is a move that you usually
want to play eventually
but queen here it's kind of a nasty
threat
oh yeah it's a john davis emote
which all the subs have access to and
thanks
left hook lawson subbing with prime
this actually reminds me i played uh i
played the ponziani
against sam sevien
who's like very strong grandmaster
i can't i'm not sure if he's still a
junior and he
he's been one of the top like juniors in
the u.s
for for many years um
i played him in the 20 i think it was a
2016
or no 2015 2015 chicago open
and he beat me as black in like 22 moves
where i played the ponziani and he just
crushed me and it was kind of sad
your voice would make a great car
navigation voice
take a left at the next turn but you
know there is an interesting line where
you take a ride
and sometimes you just drive straight
unless there's a tree right ahead then
take a left
okay so i have a check
it's not quite mate
there's a cool line bishop f7
king bishop g8
just freeing the square for the queen
what is this
it's so confusing it looks so fun though
i'm gonna have to show my uh my gaming
and sam savion after this
because we we had something kind of
similar but he played
i think he played in a much stronger way
the thing is i don't know how strong
this is because after king e7 my queen's
tied down
and this is kind of a threat
maybe it makes sense let's do it
a forcing block to bon cloud
and now probably d4
i could play a42
[Music]
so the point of a4 would be to meet
knight a5 with queen a2
just to keep the relationship between
the queen and the bishop
if i play d4 i'm allowing this and then
i would probably
have to play queen a3
and then we trade i'm not sure how great
that is for me
one more time with this move too
joking aside big fan thanks for all the
hours of chess entertainment eric
oh thanks thanks for that i'm a gruffalo
i do appreciate it i'm a little bit
perplexed here
so this this and this are my my
candidate moves there's also this
book recommendations for beginners oh
use the books command
books command will link you to my book
recommendations
what to play here
the problem is if i do this and it's
it's just kind of awkward
whoa it's moose army have a good time
okay i'm gonna play a4
i'm just trying to leave the tension
[Music]
and hopefully my opponent will be more
confused than me
thanks so much moose army that's 1500
bits
i appreciate it
oh and welcome back to axer typo yeah
sorry if i spoiled queen's gambit
earlier
i just had to show like one cool
position
what is this okay let's play d4
so in general if you're castled and the
opponent's king is in the center
this case lacking any sort of casting
rights
you want to open the center
recommendations my pleasure
thank you for the bits flying dash and
266 bits
okay so i think we have to train
[Music]
have you ever played the horde variant
on leeches
oh i have but not not for a while
actually
can't actually remember last time i
played
also i think i'm winning material here
because i have this move
and now before should trap the knight
with d5 i attack the queen and i take
away the one retreating square for the
knight
yeah at some point i'll i'll play some
horde
it's a fun variant one side has
close to 30 pawns and the other side
just has
the standard pieces
thanks for the 300 bits christian diane
and thank you marcus er cole subbing a
tier one
yeah unfortunately for black oh maybe
there's one move there's one move that
maybe
allows black to survive
i'm not going to say it but i like the
position here
i'm trying to remember like where to
find my samsevian game
because i don't think it made the
database
but i think it's i think i linked it in
an article that i wrote
from after the tournament how many
tactics puzzles do i have to solve
before i'm allowed to play a real game
um well first of all thank you for the
bits de morgan's
i mean have you not played a real game
yet are you are you brand new to chess
or when you say a real game
maybe you're referring to like a
tournament game
i mean in general i recommend having a
balance between playing and solving
okay i think black should have played
here to meet this with this because the
queen defends
um
[Music]
but yeah like in general i recommend
solving
you solving like a handful of positions
a day
or a week depending how much time you
have
okay the knight's still trapped so i
could i could take a move and defend the
pawn
oh but if i play rook d1 i allow this
because of the pin
[Music]
i have this move i think i'll play this
move
blundering upon
yeah you shouldn't feel like you have to
like get really really good at chess
before you start playing
um oh opponent took the pawn that was
nice
i mean it was kind of a free pawn
i'm not going to be winning any pawn
back
yeah it was already kind of difficult
though for black
i tried to wink i don't know if my
opponent saw my wink though
okay so
i played this move
i'm trying to make way for the the queen
it probably wasn't necessary but
okay pawn is on the quest
i hope i answered the question i don't
think i've i've been
answered or i've been asked like that
specific one
and yeah when like when you're new to
chess you really just want to play a lot
of games and
try and get some rhythm you'll you'll
learn a lot by just like getting crushed
and if you do tactics along with playing
then
and hopefully like the the patterns that
you see while doing tactics will
eventually creep into your gameplay
oh am i being a bully i can't help
myself though
i'm trying to be like a a teacher bully
like you bully them but then you teach
them some lessons
i'm bishop d hmm
looking for the knockout blow i'll just
maneuver
please help oh
um i would throw you a rope
but i don't have a rope
i have a shoelace my shoelaces broke the
other day i was playing tennis and they
just kind of snapped
what oh
sometimes forgets i forget that knights
move backwards
actually worked out nicely because
things are attacked
get crushed noob hope you learned
something
i'm not that mean am i maybe
i try not to be i try and be
at least a little bit sensitive to
people's emotions
at the same time like i'm not going to
show mercy when
i'm mating the king
okay thanks for the game random champ
gamer
played the opening wow i think it was it
was clear my opponent
was perhaps new to this line but came up
with like the main main line
and then it's been a while since i've
studied
theory here hey it's nicola
shout out to nicola solving for 23
months at tier 3.
i commentated a match nicola played like
a really cool match the other day
against sergey karjakin it was super
cool
um people can check out uh the vod
on his channel i commentated
with maria
had some really fun games i don't want
to spoil the results but
educational play-doh and how'd it go oh
over the board i mean i played the karu
in like over the board blitz
back in 20
2011.
hikaru like just crushed me like beat me
probably 30 games in a row thanks for
the game eric
you've been a huge inspiration to me oh
thank you
to one day i need to study my punzoni
theory ah
yeah um
oh thank you arc g3 and thanks nicola
also for the the 1000 bits
and thank you behemoth al subbing with
prime and
huardi also subbing
or resubbing
um there are a lot of questions there
so over the board like just casual for
fun
is probably hikaru over the world
tournament game
i played uh la quang liam
a top player from vietnam when i played
him
yeah he was already a super gm i
actually played him twice
uh in these like college tournaments
once at the the pan
ams and then once at the final four of
college chess
and he beat me both games
watching your channel has improved my
chest so much
can we celebrate my sub anniversary with
a botezz gambit
oh uh i guess my opponent helped
celebrate it in that way
queen takes b4 uh happy anniversary
uh rmt
so uh maybe i'll give a quick lesson
again in the ponziani because this line
yeah this is a line i've studied
around 2014 to 2015 like i went through
a phase where i
i played this in some tournament games
i think my score with the ponziani in
like serious tournament games was one
out of four
i lost to three different grand masters
sevien being like the strongest let me
find the game
googling my name in chicago open yeah
here we go
so i wrote an article uh
yeah 2015.
i know the site is kind of outdated but
okay the content is still here
uh oh yeah i played this was
uh this was back when i was still in fm
but this was my best tournament ever
and it secured me my fourth im norm also
the
the feed a rating um
wait where's the game
oh i think
it used to be embedded but their website
thing like did some overhaul
so i got mated after 26 moves so the
game's not here
wait let's find it
ah it's so disappointing if it's not
here
it was such a cool game too
wait let me um
let me do one thing it might be saved in
my chest-based thing
just have to open space websites from
2003 websites
from 2020. oh
are greater than oh
yeah well u.s chess like upgraded their
at least their home page
oh someone throw
little one a rope
or maybe how do you get unstuck rope
lever
maybe large tweezers i don't know
so i have a chest-based database
okay let me show this here we go
okay so this is a database it has 256
games
oh it actually has so this was my my
highest rated otb
opponent quang liam
so the hope is that it has the savion
game
um let's see sevien
ah it doesn't have it
i'll have to dig it up it's somewhere
probably in my files i
do have a shoe box with all my
like notated games from childhood
and of more recent times
i'm pretty sure i could try and remember
it
it was so long ago though
i feel like sam also played a6 though
i'm pretty sure he played queen d6
so one cool idea here is if black plays
e4 looks like an attractive move
i would play c4 queen c5 and then d4
and it's it's just a gambit basically
after it takes knight c3
i think or maybe rookie one
like white's just better here um
[Music]
and then also yeah queen d6 or c5
takes an nd for another like cool line
so um
[Music]
here
yeah i'm pretty sure sam played this and
then i played queen b3 which was a
mistake first try mr baby now
happy birthday or happy three months
oh yeah happy one-third of being a baby
we had some position like this and then
like black's king wasn't really a target
and i just got squeezed